WE DO BEGIN WITH BREAKING NEWS.
THIS MORNING. WE'RE BACK WITH
ERIC WILLIAMS AND LATAVIA
WASHINGTON MCGEE, WHO WERE
ATTACKED IN MEXICO, KIDNAPPED TO
THEIR FRIENDS WERE SHOT AND
KILLED. THEY WERE HELD HOSTAGE
SEPARATED AND BROUGHT BACK
TOGETHER. THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
PICKING UP. WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEM. YOU'RE BROUGHT FROM THE
HOSPITAL BACK TO A ANOTHER
LOCATION. THIS IS THE ONE TO
THIS WOULD BE THE THIRD PROPERTY
. YOU'RE AT THE FOURTH ONE YEAR
AT BECAUSE YOU WERE AT THE
HOSPITAL. YEAH, YEAH, YEAH,
YOU'RE RIGHT. UM SO IT MUST.
FIRST OF ALL, WHEN YOU'RE
BROUGHT BACK TO THIS HOUSE MUST
HAVE BEEN A HUGE RELIEF TO AT
LEAST BE REUNITED. FELT GOOD
BECAUSE I KEPT ASKING HIM. I
SAID I WANTED TO GO WITH MY
BROTHER. SO WHAT HAPPENED AT
THIS NEW LOCATION? I JUST KNOW
THAT I WAS IN THE CLINIC AND IT
WAS SOME PEOPLE CAME AND KNOCKED
ON THE DOOR. THEY SAID THEY CAME
IN AND BAGGED THE BODIES UP. UM
THEY SAID WE WERE GOING TO TAKE
YOU TO YOUR BROTHER, SO I
THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO TAKE A
SIGNAL TO THE HOSPITAL, BUT THEY
PUT ME IN THE BACK OF A TRUCK.
THEY PUT ME IN THE FRONT AND PUT
THE BODIES IN THE BACK. THEY
DON'T KNOW. THEY HAD ME.
BLINDFOLD COVERED UP. THEY TOOK
ME A LITTLE PIECE. WE SWITCHED
VEHICLES. THEY PUT US IN ANOTHER
VEHICLE, AND THEN THEY COVER ME
UP AND WE WROTE A LITTLE BIT AND
THEN I JUST KNOW THEY BACK THEN
SOMEWHERE, TOOK ME OUT AND TOOK
ME IN A ROOM AND I SAW HIM IN
SOME MORE PEOPLE. THERE WERE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO WERE THE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WAS CAPTAIN. I CAN'T
BELIEVE HOW MUCH YOU GUYS WERE
MOVED AROUND. I MEAN, THERE'S
GOT TO BE SO CONFUSING FOR YOU
WHEN YOU AND THEN WHAT? I THINK
WE WAS GONNA NEVER BE FOUND
BECAUSE THEY HAD POLICE SCANNERS
AND ALL TYPES OF STUFF IN THEIR
TRUCKS. SO THEY WERE LISTENING
TO POLICE. THEY KNEW THEY KNEW
WHAT WAS GOING ON. THEY ALWAYS
WAS A STEP AHEAD. RIGHT LIKE
THEY'RE NEVER GONNA FIND US LIKE
THIS. SO YOU'RE IN THAT LOCATION
NOW TOGETHER, REUNITED. YOU'RE
THERE TILL MONDAY. YOU SAID
YEAH. AND THEN WHAT HAPPENED? A
GUY CAME IN SATURDAY NIGHT.
SATURDAY NIGHT. SOMETIMES AFTER
WE END UP FALLING ASLEEP, BUT I
JUST KNOW I FELT LIKE IT WAS
DARK IN THE ROOM WE WAS AT SO
WHEN I ROLLED OVER, I COULD SEE
SOMEBODY STANDING AT THE DOOR
WITH A PHONE LIKE AND HE WAS
LIKE, CAN Y'ALL GET UP? CAN I
TALK TO YOU ALL? SO ME AND HE
SAT UP AND HE WAS LIKE, UM, HE
DIDN'T SAY Y'ALL. NO HE'S A CUTE
GET UP. GET UP. I HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY. AND, UM HE WAS LIKE
THERE'S NOTHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO BRING YOUR TWO BROTHERS BACK.
HE WAS LIKE, BUT WE'RE SORRY.
SOMEBODY MADE THE WRONG CALL.
THEY WAS HIGH AND DRUNK. AND I'M
FROM AMERICA, TOO. AND HE SAID,
UM. I'M FIGHTING WITH MY BOSS
FOR HIM TO GIVE YOU ALL UP. HE'S
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW HOW I'M GONNA
DO THIS, BUT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
GET YOUR BACK HOME. SEE YOUR
FAMILY. HE'S LIKE, I'M SORRY.
THERE'S NO WORRIES. THERE'S
NOTHING WE CAN DO TO REPAY. YOU
KNOW, HE JUST BASICALLY KEPT
SAYING HE'S SORRY. HE'S LIKE
WHEN I GIVE YOU ALL UP. I'M
GONNA LEAVE TOO, BECAUSE THEY'RE
GONNA KILL ME FROM LETTING Y'ALL
GO. HE SAID. WELL, I'M GONNA
COME BACK SUNDAY AND GET Y'ALL
BUT HE DIDN'T COME BACK TILL
MONDAY. HE COMES BACK ON MONDAY
MONDAY. AND SAYS WHAT? THEY JUST
BLINDFOLD US AND, UM BLINDFOLD
US. THEY BLINDFOLDED HIM. UH
THEY TOOK ME OUT FIRST. THEY PUT
ME IN THE BACK OF THE TRUCK. HMM
AND, UM, THEY PUT THEY PUT THE
SEAT DOWN AND PUSHED ME THROUGH
TO THE FRONT. THEN THEY BOUGHT
ERIC AND PUT HIM IN THE BACK AND
PUT SHAKE HANDS IN THEY'LL IN
THE BACK WITH HIM TO GET AHEAD
BY THESE OVERTIME AT ME. THEY
PUT YOUR FRIENDS' BODIES ON TOP
OF YOU TO HIDE FROM ME? YES. SO
THEY TOOK US TO THE OTHER
LOCATION. WE MET A TRUCK. WE SAW
ANOTHER STOP. THEY PUT THE
BODIES ON THE BACK. ME IN THE
MIDDLE AND ERIC ON THE FLOOR ON
THE FLOOR UNDER UNDER MY FEET.
YEAH. AND THEY JUST KEPT AND I
WAS LIKE, SO THEY WAS LIKE WE
PROMISED. THE MAN SAID HE
PROMISED WE'RE GONNA LET YOU GO.
WE'RE GONNA GET YOUR BAG. WE
JUST DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE GONNA
GET YOUR BACK CROSS. SO YOU'RE
DRIVING AND WHERE DO YOU END UP?
THEY JUST KEPT THEY KEPT DRIVING
US ALL NIGHT, AND THEY COULD
HAVE HIT HIM COCKING THE GUN,
STOPPING AT DIFFERENT LITTLE
INTERSECTIONS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT. I WAS THINKING HE'S
HOLDING US. HE WAS GETTING AWAY
FROM HIS BOSS. BUT AS I HEAR THE
SCANNERS, I THINK IT WAS THE
POLICE LIKE MAYBE GETTING CLOSER
TO US OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
AND THEY JUST KEPT DODGING US.
SO THEY WROTE US AROUND TO LIKE
THREE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING.
BEFORE THEY DROPPED US OFF AT
THAT CHECK THAT WAS FOUND IN
TRIED TO YOU TRIED TO GET OUT
FROM THAT SHACK. DO I DID? YEAH
YOU DID. THAT'S TRUE, AND THAT'S
REAL TRAUMA. WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN
THROUGH? HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
DEAL WITH THAT AFTERWARDS? TO
HEAR YOU, YOUR BROTHER. SOMEBODY
WHO'S YOUR FRIEND WHO COULD CALL
A BROTHER TELL YOU THEY LOVE YOU
AND YOU'RE NEVER GONNA SEE HIM
AGAIN. YOU'RE WATCHING ARE
FIGHTING FOR THEIR LIFE. AND
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO ABOUT
IT. YEAH YOU TRIED TO ESCAPE
TWICE. I MEAN, WHAT WAS WHAT WAS
BEHIND THAT? FOR MY BROTHERS TO
HAVE THE PROPER BURIAL AND FOR
US TO GO BACK HOME TO OUR FAMILY
AND KIDS. THAT WAS IMPORTANT NOT
ONLY TO GET OVER YOUR KIDS, BUT
YOUR BROTHER IS TO HAVE A
PROBLEM BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
DESERVE THAT. NONE OF NONE OF
US. NONE OF US DESERVED IT. BUT
HMM. WE ALIVE WE HAVE A LOT OF
RECOVERING THE DUDE. THEY DIDN'T
HAVE TO SUFFER, BUT I WISH THEY
WERE STILL HERE WITH US. AND I
DON'T DO WHATEVER BECAUSE I KNOW
THEY WILL DO WHATEVER FOR ME.
LISTEN I SO APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE TIME TO TALK TO US.
AND I'M SO SOR